après pratiquer le jardinage pendant
quelques années je suis amené à penser
que l'abandon des jardins et peut-être
la cause d'un certain malaise qu'on
retrouve assez souvent ou d'un état un
peu morbide de notre société et surtout
j'ai pensé que de reprendre les jardins
en main ce serait une bonne solution
pour résoudre beaucoup de nos problèmes
donc l'origine humaine on est à peu près
tous d'accord
l'animal on en est proche on est un peu
comme eux se nourrir bien se loger bien
c'est une de nos priorités de nos
nécessités quotidiennes et un peu comme
eux tout à fait comme eux depuis milan
dix mille ans en mille ans des milliers
d'années l'homme a organisé sa vie
autour du jardin pour cette nécessité
est donc une expérience de milliers
d'années pourquoi abandonner le jardin
en quelques générations là depuis
quelques gouttes d'année il abandonne le
jardin pour le remplacer par supermarché
un peu triste lieu d'éveil de jeu
pour les enfants et rendre vite les gens
à mon avis frustré frustré de ne pas
pouvoir payer ça et surtout inactifs
juste consommateurs dans un jardin on
est toujours quelque chose à faire
pendant ce temps là la nature toutes les
saisons nous s'engorge de milliers de
bonnes choses généreusement gratuitement
donc pour l'adulte je pense le jardin
peut être une thérapie pour l'enfant
c'est une éducation thérapie qu'en
individuel thérapies individuelles déjà
la contemplation sans cesse du vivant
attise la curiosité église là
l'intelligence pour un enfant et même
pour un adulte
sinon le jardinage ali bien l'esprit le
corps c'est un peu un mix entre
méditation gymnastique avec un bon repas
à la fin donc il me semble urgent de
reprendre les jardins en main comment je
pense tout le monde
tout le monde doit s'y mettre pour au
moins transmettre à nos enfants même un
mètre carré de jardin un balcon suffit à
apprendre aux enfants déjà pour redonner
une dynamique dans les écoles on devrait
apprendre le jardinage construction
d'une cabane c'est pareil hein le
logement dans les écoles on devrait
pratiquer jardinage et construction ça
devrait faire partie du programme
ensuite c'est pas une problème des
espaces beaucoup d espaces sont
disponibles les mairies pourrait mettre
à disposition des terrains
il suffit de viabiliser de fertiliser en
utilisant un peu des composts et d'avoir
l'accès à l'eau en face et les
techniques sont maintenant très simple
pour faire un jardin productif on a
ensuite accès à toutes les graines de
tous les légumes du monde c'est vraiment
facile maintenant avec nos possibilités
comparé à notre homo sapiens en s'être
les gouttes à gouttes capter l'eau c'est
vraiment des choses faciles et facile
facile ça veut dire urgent quand même et
peut-être pas trop tard
voilà
[Applaudissements]